hello everyone and welcome to the other
game I said we'd cover from the uh super
bet chess classic round three it's
Fabiano caruana versus Maxim vashiella
Grava and unlike the previous game that
we've covered ding versus uh
yanipongashi uh this one is nothing like
that this one is a miniature 23 moves
and uh well it's not something you would
expect out of a classical game but still
a very very exciting stuff so let's
check it out Fabiano Corona has the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte D4
and the maxim as he usually does goes
for uh some uh some sort of a king's
Indian or maybe a groomfield or or even
a benoni uh all depending on what Fabi
plays so here upon the C4 G6 and Fabi
strikes uh very early on with Ponte H4
now this is not a move you would expect
and Maxine has seen it before but he he
had some uh you know the different
experiences with it again some people he
played well for example against Magnus
Carlsen Magnus also played this against
Maxine he he lost terribly in the St
Louis Blitz tournament in 2019 so you
know it definitely brings back memories
so here Bishop to G7 Knight the C3 and
in the in that game against Magnus
Carlsen Maxine continued with C5 here he
goes for castles uh and now Ponte E4 so
just a standard King's Indian defense
with the sixth Bishop to E2 and now Pawn
to C5 with D5 and now while you could
play E6 for example Alexander grishukas
he is also a big fan of the spawnage for
move played this against Maxima Shiela
grav in the grand Chester Paris rapid
tournament also of 2019 but here Maxime
goes for Pawn to B5 he switches it from
a king's Indian to sort of a benoni type
setup or a Banco type setup with white
having H4 on the board and uh in the
interview after the game Fabi said that
okay I mean uh maybe perhaps even the
best you could plugins this setup is the
benoni because everyone knows that the
H4 move is a move you don't play against
the benoni or against the Bangkok it's
just useless uh but on the other hand
you're still playing the the benoni or
the benko so here uh we have C captures
on B5 A6 and now Ponta a4a capture Sun
B5 Bishop captures on B5 and now Bishop
to A6 and here uh there even is a game
where Maxine barcelograph had this exact
same position but with the white pieces
he had it against Peter's wheeler and he
won a very nice game the game continued
with Bishop to D2 but here we have
Bishop captures and A6 and it is now as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how Fabi deals with
this setup with the H4 move on the board
Knight cappers and A6 is played and now
Knight to F3 and here Queen to D7 by mvl
preparing to bring the other Rook into
the game but also uh eyeing that G4
Square now in all all sorts of um
uh well positions that could arise from
from uh from a Banco uh this C4 move is
something that you should always
consider I've played it in many
positions and it kind of always works
out well because you just give your
knight to this C5 square and from C5 the
Knight can come to B3 the Knight can
come to D3 and uh you know especially if
if there's no light Square Bishop if
it's very hard to contest the pawn sure
at some point white can go Knight to D2
and it might become a little bit weak
but um you know uh it can be done so
let's say even Bishop to E3 You're Gonna
Play Knight to B4 and now if White
Castles you will put a knight on D3 now
this is not as scary as it looks white
actually can allow this and the game
might continue even with something like
Knight D1 the B2 Pawn is pretty much
always given uh given the Black Knight
captures on B2 let's say queen C2 Knight
to D3 and now you trade captures
captures and captures and now you let's
say go Knight to the G4 and this is
something that could come up uh the the
dark Square Bishop being pressured this
uh Bishop of coming Fully Alive on this
diagonal and it's not easy for white to
make a move for example if you play
something like Bishop to D4 which
definitely makes sense this is met with
Ponte E5 and
um it's not easy to play this with white
if if anything black will be even better
here so here black should white should
go back with some like Bishop G5 or
Bishop to D2 and then the game continues
but Maxim decides to go for Queen to D7
and now we have Castles by Fabi and now
Queen to G4 and Fabi said that he really
liked this G4 move he thought it was a
very strong idea because how do you how
do you play this obviously the E4 Pawn
is hanging so you have to either defend
it or Advance it now he could Advance it
let's say uh captures and captures and
give up the H4 pawn and now what do you
make of this position you have a
beautiful Knight on E5 the d-pawn might
become strong okay you do have a past
tape on but it's not really going
anywhere so it's uh you know it's a nice
position Queen can come to F3 Rook
income T1 the pawn will come to a five
so you can definitely play it but he
decided not to rush anything just Rook
to E1 and now Knight to B4 now the
knight at some point can come to D3 uh
maybe a C4 and the D3 or maybe even this
Knight comes to H5 to F4 and then to D3
so these are all uh possibilities so
Bishop to G5 by Fabi and here he thought
that Maxim had to play something like
Rook after d8 and then kick away the
bishop and then they play a game like
this but the move that Maxim played
after Bishop to G5 completely took Fabi
by surprise he played Knights to H5
giving up the E7 pawn and this is uh I
mean this is incredibly scary this is
the base of the pawn chain if E7 Falls
then D6 is weak then C5 is weak and uh
you have to have incredible compensation
for this and the maxim is looking for
compensation in the uh in the sense that
if Knight comes to F4 he will have some
checkmating pressure on G2 also the
other Knight might come to D3 the F4
Knight will defend it so there could be
something there so let's see it Bishop
captures and he's seven uh Fabi does not
believe that this is possible Knight to
F4 and now you have to defend Checkmate
the only way to do that is to play Pawn
to G3 and now Rook F to E8 uh the
problem is with a move like Knight beta
D3 let's say it looks it looks really
strong uh the problem is a knight to G5
this is what five you found offering a
queen trade and now you have to trade
Queens there's no way to go about it
other than trading and even if you give
up the B2 Pawn we already said that in
most of these lines you will have to
give up the pawn and now even Bishop
captures an f8 wins The Exchange because
if you try to take the Rook then look at
this bishop captures and G7 and after
recap from C3 the bishop also gobbles up
the Knight and now you're up a full
Bishop so that's the problem so here
Rook FTE 8 and 5V says all right show me
Bishop captures on D6 I'm grabbing that
one as well and now I have a past the D
Pawn past a pawn where is where is your
compensation
and the problem is Maxime doesn't have
again he doesn't have Knight beta D3 uh
because Fabi would just trade captures
captures you play E5 and there's no move
for black the the position is just silly
so instead we have Knight F to D3 now
attacking the rook and going after the
B2 pawn and Fabi just plays Rook to E3
now even putting pressure on the Knight
so you can't even keep the Knight there
so Knight captures on B2 we have Queen
to B3 stopping uh at the knight from
coming to C4 so you have to go back to
D3 and now just spawn to E5 closing this
diagonal and again asking Maxim where is
your counter play Maxine plays Ponte F5
he wants to he wants to play something
he has to create something uh but Fabi
just plays Knight stage two attacks the
queen and now you have to play Queen to
D4 in the hope for the best even though
even that is a terrible position for
black but Maxine played Quinta H3 uh he
really wants to play that Ponte f for
moving uh but Fabi just played Knight to
the E2 and he was in this position on
most 23 that Maxima sheligra resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the problem is there's no
defense against uh well there's no move
for black uh whatever you play doesn't
really work uh if you place if you try
capturing a pawn let's say Bishop
capture Sunny E5 uh you just trade
everything Bishop captures Knight
cappers and even Rook captures uh
because after will captures there is
Knight F4 and the queen is trapped so
there's no there's there's no getting
out of that and even if you try
something after after this Knight to 80
move even if you try Pawn to F4 which um
okay maybe does open up this diagonal so
you can run away with the queen still
just Knight captures on F4 and after
Knight captures and F4 G captures an F4
there's nothing for you here now the
pawn Center is even more massive uh the
queen is attacked the queen has to go
back you just uh you know continue
continue the game and the black has zero
counter play here of course Maxime knows
this as he is an expert in positions
like these uh so he just resigned here
yeah uh so yeah very nicely done you can
see a totally totally different Spirit
of the game in totally different concept
than what we've seen in ding versus nepo
the ding versus Nepal are still brawling
it out as if they they were still
playing the World Chess Championship
match and here we just have a a
classical game miniature of 23 moves
where Favi completely uh crushes Maxim
with Ponte H4 it's a move that you know
has been making a sort of a re-emergence
you know it's been popular in the uh in
the 90s it's been popular uh 20 years
ago it's been popular 10 years ago it's
coming back now you know the strong
Grand Masters are are starting to play
but like Fabi said in his opinion it is
definitely Alexander grishuk who is to
to blame for for this increased
popularity of H4 in this position and in
many other positions
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for suggesting such
uh such a nice game Fabi uh improving if
he's reading a little bit but also his
standings in the tournament it's now
it's now like a five-man tie so we're
not going to discuss the standings once
we have a sort of an imbalance then
we're gonna show the standings and
discuss it a little bit uh until then
we're just enjoying the games enjoying
the tournament and we'll see what
happens uh in in round four so yeah I
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Edmund Freeman Evan bursi
ravishing reptiles YouTube Lord of Bones
and Mazin El sarag for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
sorry about the weird audio quality for
the first minute of the previous video I
I never change anything in my setup it's
just that sometimes you know the the
audio becomes weird I have no idea why
that happens so really sorry about that
see you soon